it doesn't matter who you are you know
um
you can be like laverne cox you know
like whatever that means
um and yeah if you're trans you know it
just doesn't you know you're gonna
you're gonna experience stuff like this
laverne cox is giving her fans an update
on her well-being after she experienced
a transphobic attack
nearly two weeks ago in los angeles
griffith park
he aggressively like asked for the time
as he passes us
and my friend who i'm with that tells
him the time and looks at his watch and
tells him the time
and then the guy who had asked for the
time
says to my friend guy or girl
my friend says oh i'm walking i'm
hearing all this is happening like in a
split second
and then all of a sudden the guy is
attacking my friend
and i look back and i'm like i was like
what is happening the guy's like hitting
my friend
and then my friend is like going towards
him and i'm like
holy and i pull out my phone i call
9-1-1
to dial 9-1-1 and all of a sudden it's
over and the guys is gone well speaking
with the hollywood reporter the actress
opened up about how she has been doing
since the deeply
triggering incident i'm really grateful
that
i got out of this situation physically
safe it's been really important for me
to understand that that moment
was deeply triggering for me because of
my whole history my whole lifetime
of not feeling safe in public because of
my gender expression but now laverne
explains she is focused
on healing herself leaning deeply into
my trauma resiliency work
over the past week and grateful for that
work i'm grateful that there are ways to
stay present and work through trauma
when it happens
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos